what do you think you will be surprised
to learn about the other person there
anything that surprised about this good
yeah I mean as a Zed or just as me as
you or what would be probably surprised
about what would people be surprised I
learned about Patrick Wilson like if
there does he break easily you know like
she doesn't she's rock solid you know he
does break easily
you break easily I'm in the moment you
know I mean like somebody's genuinely
funny in front of me I'm gonna give them
the proper respect and laugh break that
easily she's locked in what draws the
two of you to the story of the Warrens
what you coming back oh man well we have
fun I think you know to be a gift 20
seconds of being serious we're both
extremely you know I will speak on
behalf of you that's what I will do very
devout family members and love our
families more than anything else in this
world so if you're gonna go away it
better be for a really good reason and
certainly you're gonna keep going back
to the well to of characters that you've
played before so yes creatively you want
to push these characters in places they
never been but if you didn't have fun
other people you're working with it's
just this little life is too short
nailed it nailed it I am not bad I think
I was reading somewhere that you know
you scare easily and you know did
Annabelle ever end up in a place that
she wasn't maybe supposed to be during
shooting the see the dot yeah I wouldn't
scare her no she wouldn't get scared
about the dog doll doesn't scare me
because the the doll is an inanimate
object there's like there's not
everybody keeps things like dander
though has it it's not there's a demon
that surrounds Annabelle that we should
be afraid I'm is Greg
that about for Isabel Riggs doesn't
quite have that scary ring to it Gary
Griggs gregor hmm
that's correct and gore oh I like it
this really helped you have a wonderful
group of cramps look like you know young
actresses doctors you're right sorry
what was it like sort of seeing them
don't care elite or dominate this they
do see that we young ladies yes
starring and in a big Hollywood movie
that's awesome yeah they they shouldered
the load and that was you know that was
really fun to see because it's this it's
a new experience for us seeing you know
we shot our stuff pretty tight and
whatever was a week or so and then they
would offer basically shot the movie so
it was very refreshing to to sit back
and enjoy it as a fan and watched all
the work that they did they're awesome